je vais commencer par vous raconter une
histoire mon histoire
j'étais un élève de 3e dans un lycée
douillet du 7e arrondissement
j'avais des résultats scolaires moyens
voire très très moyen alors les profs
ont soufflé à l'oreille de mes parents
qu'il serait souhaitable d'envisager
un cycle court c'est-à-dire en fin de
troisième de m'orienter vers un lycée
professionnel
alors je me suis retrouvé devant une
conseillère d'orientation qui après
m'avoir fait passer une batterie de
tests psychologiques
m'a posé la question suivante
alors jeune homme qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire comme métier
Jacques castache là on sait pas ce qu'on
va faire après demain
un peu difficile de répondre à la
question
alors j'ai répondu cuisinier je ne sais
pas pourquoi peut-être m'abonner toi ou
quelqu'un à la haut qui m'a soufflé ça à
l'oreille
en tous les cas j'étais vraiment pas
prédestiné à faire ce beau métier de
partage de générosité au service des
autres car fils de notaire dans les
années 70 c'était plutôt ce métier était
plutôt considéré comme une voie de
garage alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
voix de futurs stars
et oui
mais dès mon apprentissage sans le
savoir
j'étais déjà un cuisinier
éco-responsable alors pourquoi sans le
savoir parce que
à l'aube des années 80 on ne parlait pas
d'antigaspille on ne parlait pas
d'approvisionnement local de saison car
pour certains c'était une normalité et
d'autres il l'avait oublié
ça c'était le monde d'hier
mais dans le monde de demain
qu'allons-nous manger qu'allons-nous
mettre dans nos assiettes
alors il faut se poser trois questions
la première ou en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui la seconde
quelles sont les défis la troisième
quelles sont les solutions
aujourd'hui
sur Terre nous sommes en 2023 8
milliards de trois humains
les prévisions pour 2050 sont de 10
milliards alors que s'épuisent les
ressources naturelles et s'intensifient
le réchauffement climatique
nous consommons beaucoup de protéines
animales trop de protéines animales
depuis les années 50 depuis 1950 nous
avons multiplié par 7 notre consommation
de viande bovine
qui comme tout le monde le sait très
impactante pour le climat mais aussi
très impactante au niveau de l'eau
à titre indicatif il faut
15000 litres d'eau je dis bien quinze
millilitres de don pour produire un kilo
de steak de steak ou de viande moving
concernant nos océans ce magnifique
garde-manger comme l'aime le nommer le
Chef Olivier rollinger nos océans sont
menacés en effet la plupart des espèces
de poissons sont sur exploitées et
menacés d'extinction
et enfin
vous ne savez peut-être pas mais chacun
d'entre nous chaque année on gaspille 30
kilos de nourriture
30 kg de nourriture c'est à dire 10
millions de tonnes en France de
nourriture
alors ça c'est la réalité notre système
alimentaire à l'heure actuelle
quels sont les défis
l'idéal je dirais qu'il faudrait
produire plus pour nourrir plus en
préservant une qualité alimentaire
il va donc falloir modifier notre façon
de travailler en agriculture
afin qui est très énergivore en pétrole
afin de en fait réduire l'empreinte
carbone
l'empreinte eau préserver nos sols tout
en réduisant les pesticides
et puis selon la FAO l'organisation
mondiale des Nations Unies il va falloir
produire encore plus au niveau de
l'agriculture il va falloir augmenter de
70% notre production agricole alors que
nous ne pourrons augmenter que de 4 à 5%
les terres les terres cultivées
alors quelles sont les solutions
et bien vous savez la première solution
elle est la portée de tous
c'est le gaspillage alimentaire
et le gaspillage alimentaire il commence
chez nous
on se souvient tous
moi compris
avoir mis le verre de poireaux à la
poubelle pour utiliser que le blanc
on souvient tous avoir mis directement
la carcasse de poulet à la poubelle
alors qu'on aurait pu la mettre dans une
casserole avec de l'eau
et faire un bouillon pour le lendemain
ou le surlendemain
on a tous et que tu es un peu rapidement
des fraises en laissant une partie rouge
de la fraise sur la queue et mettre tout
ça à la poubelle donc vraiment c'est
quelque chose de très facile
s'approvisionner localement de saison
c'est bon pour notre santé puisqu'on va
consommer des produits frais puisqu'ils
auront très frais parce qu'ils auront
beaucoup moins voyagé et comme ils
auront voyagé moins voyagé c'est ils
seront beaucoup moins impactants pour la
planète
n'utiliser que des produits
que des poissons issus de la pêche
durable alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
un poisson
issue de la pêche durable c'est un
poisson dont les stocks sont
suffisamment importants pour ne pas
mettre en péril les espèces c'est un
poisson qui est suffisamment grand c'est
à dire qu'il y a eu sa maturité sexuelle
qui s'est reproduit avant qu'on le mange
et c'est un poisson qui a été bien pêché
donc avec des méthodes de pêche durable
qui n'ont pas saccagé
les fonds marins mais aussi l'autre
solution c'est de changer notre façon de
notre de nous alimenter
vous savez
être respectueux l'environnement être
attentif à notre panette ce n'est pas et
ce ne doit pas être punitif c'est
trouver des solutions
pour continuer de jouir à se réjouir des
plaisirs de la vie
alors je vous dis pas de devenir
végétarien ou vegan je respecte tout à
fait les personnes dans la salle qui le
sont qui ont choisi ce régime
alimentaire
mais c'est en fait modifier le contenu
de nos assiettes en réduisant
drastiquement les protéines animales et
on augmentant les végétaux et protéines
végétales afin de garder un équilibre
alimentaire ça c'est important et garder
cette cette notion de plaisir
qu'allons-nous manger demain dans le
monde de demain en 2050 alors
rassurez-vous pas des pilules
d'abord parce que quand même le
souligner Éric
birdouest qui est un sociologue
spécialiste expert en alimentation en
agriculture l'être humain ne se nourrit
pas de nutriments mais d'aliments qu'il
transforment qu'il cuisine
et pour faire sourire un chercheur de
l'inrae il y a quelques années a fait
une étude qui selon lui
pour obtenir 2000 kcal notre besoin
quotidien il faudrait avaler chaque jour
350 pilules de 1 g avec 5 litres d'eau
donc on est très loin de la notion de
plaisir on va laisser ça à nos
astronautes pour aller sur Mars ou
d'autres galaxies
ça c'est certain et
mais par contre nous allons
introduire dans notre alimentation
des produits qui ne font pas partie de
notre culture
je vous parlais en premier des insectes
alors certains connaissent déjà
[Musique]
le collège des insectes sous forme de
farine on les utilise beaucoup à l'heure
actuelle
pour réaliser des gâteaux mais je vous
parle des insectes entiers parce que
c'est vrai vous pouvez grimacer mais on
en mange déjà un peu enfin qui ressemble
les insectes les crevettes par exemple
il y a déjà une carapace une antenne
donc pourquoi pas
et les insectes ont l'avantage d'être
très protéiné d'être 100 fois moins
impactant que l'élevage bovine
et de pouvoir être élevé
sur des surfaces assez réduites je vais
vous parler aussi des algues les algues
on les connaît tous on nage à côté quand
on va se baigner dans la mer mais c'est
vrai que ça fait pas tellement partie de
notre culture et sont très appréciés par
les asiatiques vous connaissez peut-être
la l'étude mère le wakamé le nori le
kombu
elles sont très nutritives mais
l'avantage des algues c'est que au-delà
d'avoir 145 espèces comestibles
dont la plupart proviennent de nos côtes
elles n'ont ni besoin d'eau douce ni
besoin de pesticides ça c'est plus haut
très bon pour nous pour le climat
et en plus elles sont très faciles à
cuisiner on peut les cuisiner des
hydraté fraîches en saumure et faire des
plats merveilleux comme des bouillons
des condiments des soupes après un
aliment du futur qui va arriver mais
peut-être pas tout de suite peut-être
pas tout de suite c'est la viande de
laboratoire la viande de synthèse
pourquoi pas tout de suite parce que
déjà ça a un coût énorme de grandes
entreprises travaillent sur ce sujet ils
ont des problèmes de coups des problèmes
de Tux de texture et de saveurs donc ces
trois problèmes à résoudre
et pour vous donner une idée d'ailleurs
c'est pas très vieux le premier steak de
laboratoire a été créé en 2013 c'est un
chercheur néerlandais qui l'a créé il
s'appelle Marc poste
et ça lui a coûté la somme de 2250 000
euros donc là effectivement on est quand
même loin de la consommation de tous les
jours
après il y a les fermes verticales alors
ça ça concerne principalement les fruits
et légumes
ça sera l'avantage de faire médical
c'est que ça prend très peu de place sur
terre donc on va donc qui avons un
problème de de terre cultivables ça peut
résoudre ce problème là en plus on peut
les mettre à l'intérieur des villes à
l'extérieur des villes d'ailleurs il en
existe déjà une à Romainville juste à
l'extérieur de Paris ça répondra quelque
part à
une attente
des personnes qui habitent dans ces
villes dans ces grandes métropoles à
pouvoir manger local plus facilement
on va passer un peu dans la
science-fiction je vais vous parler des
imprimantes 3D je n'y crois pas du tout
donc rassurez-vous ça me rappelle trop
ce fameux film Louis de Funès ou la
cuisse je me vois pas en train de
préparer mon assiette avec une
imprimante 3D et je crois que ça et
j'espère qu'on ne le fera jamais
mais par contre
pour réduire l'empreinte carbone pour
nous aider à optimiser les produits pour
nous aider à réduire l'effort physique
je crois beaucoup à l'arrivée de la
robotisation en cuisine alors
rassurez-vous
quelque part pas dans les cuisines
étoilées les cuisines de prestige ou là
l'artisanat sera toujours de rigueur
avec de vrais cuisiniers
et avec surtout le consommateur qui
pourra payer
des additions salées
mais dans les cuisines plus abordables
et cuisine de restaurants on peut se
payer tous les jours
il y aura toujours un cuisinier qui sera
là pour créer ses recettes mais qui
seront mis en œuvre par ses bras
robotisés
et qui
permettront de réduire l'effort physique
tout en garantissant une qualité
alimentaire et en respectant
l'environnement et vous verrez
très rapidement ça arrivera chez vous
dans vos cuisines
pour conclure je dirais que
notre alimentation de demain ne se fera
qu'avec
le retour au vrai valeur
respect du monde animal
respect et valorisation nos agriculteurs
tout en l'ordonnant de nouvelles
technologies afin qu'ils puissent
réduire l'empreinte carbone et réduire
l'empreinte eau et nourrir la population
nomade mondiale
notre alimentation de demain c'est nous
tous qui allons la construire avec notre
bon sens
nous devons rester maître de notre
alimentation
nous devons être des consonnes acteurs
merci
[Applaudissements]